Washington DC experienced a mild
snowfall last week
luckily city councilman Trey on white
was on it he knows why it happened
watch this just out of snoring out of
nowhere this morning man y'all better
pay attention to this climate control
man
it's a crime of manipulation and DC
keeps talking about we're resilient city
and that's a model based off the
Rothschilds controlling the climate
secrete natural disaster they can pay
for it all the cities might be careful
yep the Rothschilds control the climate
the watch shots of course are a wealthy
Jewish banking clan they're included in
a great many conspiracy theories but
those theories rarely give them credit
for the weather that's an ambitious new
twist mark Stein is an author and
columnist and a part-time meteorologist
and he joins us tonight what do you make
it so this is by the way I live here so
you can laugh all you want but that's
actually my City Councilman speaking
there
the Rothschilds control the weather did
you know that well I did actually
Tucker they've they bought the weather
from God 1929 when he had a bit of a
liquidity problem video Wall Street
Crash and they keep it in the wine
cellars at the Chateau Mouton Rothschild
estate in France and that they're able
to micro-target the climate for example
it was light snow in your part of
Washington but I gather in the stairwell
of Traian White's apartment building he
actually had an avalanche just on his
floor that's that's how micro-targeted
the big to weather machine is able to be
you may think it's a light snowfall but
if you actually examine it it's actually
small pieces of gefilte fish which is
why it doesn't melt and that's why the
Jews control the snow plow business so
they scoop all the gefilte fish in
Washington away and they use it to make
louis farrakhan calypso albums which
they put out to discredit the
with Farah Khan from telling the truth
about the synagogue of satan' it all
makes sense see the funny thing is I
don't know if it's funny it's actually
so appalling and shocking that its huh
it's what I'm just gonna laugh about it
that was that was what you made me feel
better about a city out of control so
then I want to run this by me maybe you
can make me feel better about this too
there's a new uproar on social media
over microaggressions at UC Santa Cruz
the school has assembled a list of
microaggressions it warns that phrases
like America is the land of opportunity
and I believe the most qualified person
should get the job are offensive and
verboten the weirdest thing though the
scariest thing this list has been in use
for years and there's no sign it's going
away do you abide by this list mark I
thought it was an interesting list it's
interesting they banned the expression
America is a land of opportunity because
America is a land of opportunity let's
say you're a person with no talents but
a degree of hucksterism who's figured
out that you could get a job a tenured
job as the assistant dean of
microaggressions and put teenagers
saddle them with six figures of debt for
attempting to criminalize basic social
interactions by holding big lectures on
microaggressions now now America is such
a land of opportunity you can clean up
big time if you do that if you try to do
that in say Sudan no one will come to
your lecture on microaggressions because
in Sudan they think you were an obvious
huckster and the only people who'd be in
your lecture would be a camel who came
in to get out of the rain and some guy
and his child bride who'd actually taken
a wrong turn on the way to the female
genital mutilation clinic but so only
America is such a boundless land of
opportunity that becoming an expert if
you become an expert in microaggressions
young people will saddle themselves with
the quarter million dollars of debt just
to receive your wisdom even by your high
standards tonight was an all-time-high
war
mark thank you Mark Steyn you you made
me feel so much better I can't even
stand it I appreciate it
[ __ ] [ __ ] sellout Tucker always the plan
yeah